schools reopening should not be a
politicized topic
we should let science guide us to make
the best possible decision
it's not going to be a perfect one but
it's going to be the best one we can do
in our given situation and adapt as we
go
here i sit down with dr david epstein to
talk about schools reopening
who's a pediatric icu physician who also
works in a pediatric urgent care
right on the front lines during coven
19. enjoy dr epstein i want to welcome
you to the channel
tell me your background tell me why you
would be
one of the best people if not the best
person to talk about this subject
well thank you dr barzowski i really
appreciate you inviting me to the
conversation
um well i'm i'm boarded in pediatrics
and i did sub specialty training in
pediatric critical care medicine
um i worked a few years at ucla
and then worked about 10 14 years
at children's hospital los angeles and
the cardiac thoracic icu
there and over the last five years i've
opened up a pediatric urgent care
in which we've been caring for children
on the front lines
with urgent care needs so being exposed
to a lot of variety of illness in
pediatrics from
those that are minor to those that are
are quite life-threatening
since we're going to be talking about
the subject of schools reopening i guess
the first
thought that everyone has is are
children going to be safe
because they're going to be exposed to
other children who potentially could be
spreading this virus
california in general uh maybe about
nine eight or nine percent of the total
positive population
has been children i want to make a
statement and you correct me if you
think it's wrong or perhaps you'll agree
with me
if i had a five-year-old child
and i was faced with this very weird
hypothetical situation where to choose
between them getting the influenza virus
or covet 19
i think i would want my child to get
coveted 19 because
statistically at least right now it
looks like they fare better with the
virus would you agree
of the kids less than 17 years of age
california hasn't documented any deaths
less than 17 years of age
you know most of the deaths have been in
the population greater than 65
years of age so i have to think of it in
in terms of
morbidity and mortality things like that
and so from a mortality standpoint it
seems like
you know kids the population it's it's
it seems to be almost negligible as far
as mortality when you talk about kids
who die from influenza
that seems to be a very rare event as
well i mean i think
annually there's probably about 180 kids
that die from
influenza um per year and i'm sure the
national numbers for
kids dying from covid is not negligible
i'm sure that you know there are a
number of cases
so you're you're trying to you're trying
to
balance that the concern is and the
anxiety is that
you have a vaccine for influenza you
have treatment for one
for influenza and you're still only
having you know you're still having a
mortality of 186 children which
you feel is kind of more preventable
when you're talking about covid you
don't have any of the that safety net
as far as treatment or vaccine i think
the anxiety of not knowing what could
happen
is an issue because we're we're worried
about you know kids who have may have
underlying uh illnesses like
juvenile idiopathic arthritis or they
may have
some other immunodeficiency or they may
be immunocompromised and they may not
show up
on the mortality board but they may show
up on the morbidity board
of getting more severe disease and
having issues with their medications
and and and having them step back while
the numbers
don't look bad as far as mortality and
contagion and having kids
passing along to adults i think some
some
anecdotal reports have said that maybe
the index case of children passing the
adults is probably nine percent or
something like that and so
they don't seem to be passing along for
you know the young young kids
i think your answer is very fair that we
don't know what that answer is we can
lean one way or another in the moment
looking at the current evidence that may
shift as more evidence comes out
because for example we see this low
index number that you mentioned
which is this how easily children spread
this virus and we think okay maybe
they're not spreading it as much
we see the lower number of that
multi-inflammatory syndrome
being not so high and we think okay not
so bad but did those
radically change when we go back to
school very possible right yeah yeah and
we and we don't we don't know that yet
and i think you know a lot of countries
around the world are
are going back to school in various
forms or fashions but
we have to think that you know it's only
we're looking at something that's only
gone over months
you know and and the information we have
on influenza is
years in the icu we we like to know what
we're dealing with we don't like to
know about the unknown and so having
that uh
you know things be a little bit more
concrete and known as a little bit more
comforting to us
control we're controlling you know as
physicians we oftentimes have to make
recommendations with limited evidence
that happens quite often you know a b or
c level recommendation
and we have to give that to our patients
because that's what we know in a given
moment what i think is going to happen
is
in some way we're going to return back
to school or return back to normal
and we have to be flexible enough and
adaptable enough to pivot
at any given moment that's why in my
stance
it makes sense to either a delay school
until we have more information and not
be hard set by these deadlines where you
know by august 7th we have to have a
decision
well if we don't have the good info to
guide us then maybe we can push that a
few weeks
and see what happens because ultimately
we're trying to play this game of risks
and balances
without all the cards on the table and
perhaps if we buy ourselves two weeks if
we
allow a study to be finished we'll be
able to make a better decision
uh for schools for parents for teachers
all of the above what are your thoughts
on teacher safety and
all of the conversation that's
surrounding teachers being safe
around children in covid 19 era i think
in general pediatricians are
in favor of going back to school in some
form or fashion
while we take into account the pediatric
standpoint
oftentimes i think we forget about the
teachers who are the adults in the
classroom and different countries around
the world have had
had some experience and i know we hear
about uh
israel and germany and you know in
israel there was a lot of contagion and
they had to shut back down and
uh their teachers were affected and and
in kids
in germany i think there was less so i
think it was more uh
spread by children and and or spread
amongst
kids and not so much staff um
every country seems to be a little bit
different i think that we're still
learning
and i do think that the teachers have a
voice in all this because it's their
lives that are online and some of them
may be
elderly we have to be honest and talk
about the disparities
in socioeconomic factors that some
schools are dealing with a lot less
resources than others
i've been my entire childhood i've went
to
inner city schools and i've seen how
they've had to manage with low resources
and i can't imagine some of these things
that are on the cdc checklist
being accomplished while i think it's
great and the cdc put out the correct
recommendations
just from a realistic standpoint where
are you going to get these employees
that are going to be doing contact
tracing
where are you going to be getting
substitute teachers from
when teachers who are elderly can't come
in or when someone has
an immunocompromised state or checking
on students who didn't come in because
their parents are sick
it just there's so many variables that
it's impossible to get a perfect
scenario
so we have to lose that idea of
perfection right away and
be open to this nuanced conversation
where perhaps there's not a
one-size-fits-all solution
especially on a geographic level like
what works in an area where there's low
infectivity
versus where it's peaking has to be
completely different i want to ask you a
pointed
very difficult question what is your
stance on school's reopening
yeah no i think i think that's a very
good question and i
something that i've been thinking about
a lot because i have school age children
and you know
they're going back you know i need to go
back to school and um
i i vote for going back to school
um bottom line for one reason
specifically okay well this is good
so so i agree with everything that you
said
in as much as every every
area of the country is going to be
different what works in
you know the middle of montana is not
going to work in the middle of los
angeles
you know or you know los angeles county
so it there are different geographic
areas there are different places that
have different incidents
of disease and so the precautions
will likely be different and we have to
shape those accordingly
and like you said there are disparities
in districts and it's going to be hard
to accommodate all those recommendations
which are the right thing
the reason why i believe that that kids
need to be going going back to school
the important things are a the education
and i know that
in some districts they may not have the
ability to do
uh uh remote learning yeah tele
education
those kind of things as adequately as
other areas
um the other things are uh
just the socialization of children
children like
respond and map out their world
depending on the context they make right
now we're creating like a
two-dimensional environment
for our kids and for us and really as
human beings we develop in a
three-dimensional
world with that contact with other
people those exchanges those kind of
things
and it's very difficult for kids because
their their learning and their
development
depends on that and you look at uh i
mean one of the things that i've seen in
the in the
uh in the clinic is seeing people
adolescence
and this is near the end of the school
year
having physical manifestations of their
anxiety
their depression their uh
their isolation from their peers not
being able to go to prom
not being able to graduate with their
peers not be able to interact in this
most
important milestone of their lives and
granted
you know at that time that's that's a
very very important thing in their life
and so going back to school means a lot
of those things
and go not going back to school in
isolation
kind of it promotes almost it's almost
like a traumatic event
you know the educational aspects the the
trauma that develops from isolation i
think those are very very real concerns
obviously we have to balance this with
the medical aspects and as
as a physician i'm i'm extremely torn
because i know the potential and having
worked in the icu
and and being in the clinic and and
hearing about what's going what when
what new york went through i have images
in my mind
and understand that how severe things
can get
and so trying to balance
those issues with the issues of children
not going back to school
is a very very real thing but i i do
advocate for going back to school but
you mentioned one important word in in
your
uh in your explanation of why you you
felt you know going back to or going
back to school was important or
how to go back to school and that's the
word pivot
and i really like that term because
we have to be flexible and we have to
reassess it's like the the
the plan do study act cycle you know of
quality improvement i mean we have to
assess what we've done and we have to
modify depending on what the outcome is
and so it shouldn't be
like you said a very concrete you know
yes at all costs no it all costs it has
to be somewhere
somewhere in between you know i
completely agree with you on the topic
of opening schools
at the same time if i'm a teacher and
i'm elderly or i'm not elderly or i have
someone in my home that's elderly
and i want to teach it sounds like
you're saying the children's
social educational development
is more important than my safety how
would you respond to that i'm strictly
playing devil's advocate here that's a
very hard thing i mean i wouldn't want
to put teachers
lives at risk by any means um you know
there's going to be more data as time
goes i would hope that
schools would find a way to be able to
pivot or be able to
do things in a way that can make it safe
for teachers
but i do think it's important for kids
to go back to school and
you know maybe if it had you know maybe
if it is
you know some form of uh you know mixed
uh tele-education
uh live education uh i know that a lot
of countries
and a lot of schools that are been
planning have been doing
planning pods and shifts of when kids go
back so you're creating smaller
environments creating more
distancing having kids wearing masks
creating
you know regular hand washing you know
screening kids
by you know temperature although that's
not always accurate
um having kids sit out who are who have
been sick
unfortunately we're forced to be in a
position of choosing
the lesser of two evils almost like a a
rationing of care situation which we
obviously hate in the healthcare space
basically rationing of care is when you
have two patients and you only have one
ventilator you have to make the choice
who's
more likely to benefit from this that's
almost what we're doing uh when we're
saying
you know should we open schools or not
because we see the detrimental effects
to kids on a mega scale
and we see the potential risk for
teachers because at this moment it's a
potential risk we don't know it for
certain because
we don't have the data to back that up
so we're sort of saying okay look
there is this potential danger but we
know this
other danger for children most
definitely exists so let's start up in a
gradual approach and build up
and continually reassess our strategies
will teachers
uh have negative outcomes from this into
some degree yes we have to be honest
about it
will teachers catch covet 19 if schools
reopen yes we just have to say that
saying anything otherwise is a lie as
our federal leaders go on television
if they just say oh it's no big deal no
one's going to suffer that's a lie
the approach that i feel has worked best
for me in the healthcare space
has been the most upfront that you can
be with
what you're doing why you're doing it
and how you will pivot
if information changes and once you can
get the people who you're treating
in this situation teachers on the same
page as to why you're making these
decisions
the more likely they are to to accept
the outcome and
i feel that the federal government the
media has done a really poor job
arming teachers with good information
about what risks they face what
mitigation strategies they can use
because some of the things listed in the
cdc manuals
are just impossible for many school
districts like the six foot rule is
great
it's not even a perfect rule but it's
not realistic for many schools so
perhaps we need to downgrade to the
three foot rule that the who set forth
perhaps we could move some classrooms
outdoors where we see less transmission
there's all these things that are being
pushed aside of the conversation
in favor of a political talking point
that really should not be
anywhere in this discussion politics
should mean the least
when it comes to opening schools because
at the end of the day whether you're an
independent republican democrat your
child is your child
and if you have a family member that has
children or has a teacher in their
family
you should care equally for them
communication is really important and i
think communication with teachers
is going to be ultimately important and
trying to educate them
with regards to what information we have
on
covid right now which like you said it's
very imperfect
and we're still learning and we need to
reassess but
i think to have have two groups suffer
needlessly you know children and
teachers
is wrong um i think and
we have to balance each of their each of
their
their needs and we have to reassess i
mean it's
it has to be a very balanced approach
let's take some time and talk about
the outliers in this situation you know
we've mentioned
social determinants of health we
mentioned lower socioeconomic school
districts
you know there are schools out there
that receive funding from property taxes
in very wealthy neighborhoods that can
you know put acrylic
across acrylic is that plastic
see-through covering you see in some of
the
stores and medical offices they could
put that across the entire classroom
and then there's some areas where that's
going to be completely impossible
there's some areas where students
rely on school for feeding their
children
some areas that require the schools so
that they can get to work themselves
because they don't have child care
options available to them
unless we bring all of these very
important pieces
of the conversation to the table we're
going to be leaving a significant
population of the u.s behind
and that's not good either i can easily
see two individuals
on this subject you know a teacher on
one end who's immunocompromised and is
worried about going back to school
and at the same time i could see a
parent in a low
socioeconomic neighborhood of a special
needs child
saying i need my child to go back to
school i can't care for them
without without going broke because i
need to go to work or i don't have the
ability to teach them because i'm not
trained in this
and both sides are right in what they're
saying
they both need to be heard but where do
you go from there
that's where i struggle myself even at
times well i don't think you're alone i
mean i think the whole country is
struggling with that i think there are a
lot of people
i mean if it was if it was easy
you know we wouldn't be having these
discussions i mean really we wouldn't if
everything was going
the way it should be going but there are
a lot of competing
demands and trying to prioritize one
over another sometimes is
is very difficult but uh we do have to
invest in our children
and you know the children are our future
people watch this conversation you and i
speak
they understand where both you and i are
coming from what is
the one line you want to leave them with
yeah you know i
um the things that we're doing aren't
hard
to prevent this and the one thing that i
if we work together you know we're going
to get through this a lot
easier and a lot quicker and so if
you're wearing a mask
if you're doing simple things like
trying to distance yourself
washing your hands not touching your
face staying
away if you have cold symptoms these are
very very simple things to do
there's a lot of controversy surrounding
these topics and a lot of pushback
on doing certain things because
it's not what we're used to it's not
what we feel comfortable with
this is going to be something that's
transient and the time that we invest
now
on prevention and spread it's going to
pay off in dividends in the future
because we'll be able to go back to work
sooner we'll be able to be comfortable
with having our kids in school
sooner without restrictions you know
there's a lot of things so the sooner
that we can implement these things
and be more uh uh work as a team
yeah that you know we're gonna get
through this a lot quicker
check out this great interview with the
psychologist who talks about good
intentions
having bad outcomes or check out me
hanging out with my man
dr fauci click it click it and as always
stay happy and healthy
you